this show is brought to you by Blue
Apron Blue Apron is the number one fresh
ingredient and recipe delivery service
in the
country check out this week's menu and
get your first three meals for free with
free shipping by going to blueapron.com
jooy that's right get your first three
meals for free and you get free shipping
at blueapron.com
Joey show is also brought to you by ceso
s o ceso is the new ad free streaming
service bringing you bingeable hilarious
original series and streaming comedy
anywhere on your phone TV tablet and
more go to seo.com Joey right now to get
your first two months for free that's
seo.com Ander promo code
Joey kick that [__] mu
Le it's Wednesday [__]
morning oh
[Music]
what's really Tuesday night David
Bowie's anniversary out of
[Music]
respect the Church of What's Happening
Now The Flying Jew
lisat and his Cuban
Uncle here we
go
[Music]
take things
over lose to
swallow put there are just you thought
it was
safe greetings [__] we're back
from the podcast World hope you guys are
doing well today myself Lis
sayat I guess canceled at 6 fucking3 who
does something like that but what are
you going to do that's when you deal
with when you live in California with
these [__] uh oh my God egg white
[__] it's it's a it's a flood
it's a Dr it's it's a downpour I'm like
it's crazy people it's I'm not even
turning my my windshield wipers off if
you [__] you know since last week
we've been hearing about these storms
we're going to get in Southern
California the [__] clouds and they
show people around the country so I have
my friends calling me going oh my God
you got 20 in of snow I'm like I'm
looking at [__] Sunshine what are you
talking it's like the other day they
said they got 2 feet of snow in New York
they called my buddies like what are you
talking about we got 5 Ines the [__]
media report the weather report there's
such [__] I don't ever since I lived
in Colorado I don't believe the weather
anyway like I don't believe the weather
especially here in Southern California I
don't believe it till it's here cu the
sun fights to [__] get out of here
everywhere else it Taps out like if you
live on the east coast it just Taps out
for like three days here the sun fights
the death if they get moisture from the
beach something the sun fights to death
to get out here it's always out and it
that even here where it's it's the same
every day that they're they're always
wrong back in back East they're wrong
just because stuff can change in a
second it doesn't take a [__] genius
Le that if it's raining here today it's
going to be snowing on the East Coast by
Fred it don't take a [__] genius it's
raining here today it's going to snow in
[__] Cleveland on Saturday don't I
knew it was going to snow once I saw the
rain I go this ain't going to be [__]
good I was going to take a connecting
flight and I said you know what I'm
going to squash that [__] idea
because both connections one was in
Denver which you don't know what the
[__] is going to happen
there good place to get stuck though you
got a massage your feet cut they could
sniff your toenail they'll do everything
at the Denver Airport they don't give a
[__] they'll [__] cut your hair
there's a room where you can take a nap
oh yeah pay they got everything at
Denver but the other airport that I had
a layover in Chicago I said you know
what
[__] that noise that [__] Airport's
the kiss of death that's the [__]
Kiss of Death that [__] place every
connecting flight is late plus your
flight's always two miles away so you're
never going to make it just on [__]
principle you should sit sit and watch
those flights when you get there just
watch the flights and see if they were
delayed where in Chicago and in Colorado
yeah whenever you get to oh no no I'm
just listen I'm going to fly I'm going
to get the [__] out of here flight free
non-stop no drama okay I'll get upgraded
by [__] the time I fly on Thursday
everything will be
beautiful that oh yeah when you get
upgrades it's funny I looked in the
plane today there's nobody in that
[__] section so they better give me a
[__] ticket do you see do you know
where you are on the list yet or not yet
they don't tell you till no they don't
tell you but I got clout you know what
I'm saying I know people I don't know
nobody at United those [__] I
know nobody oh you see the a plane got
turned around have you ever had that a
plane got turned around they were going
from Australia to San Francisco and this
dude was sitting in in in between two
apparently Indian guys and he started
getting mad and saying racist stuff they
turned the plane around and made it land
in New Zealand and make him and had him
get off and they'll arrest you oh yeah
they said they said that he had to wait
in jail until another airline agreed to
take him home cuz United what United
wasn't going to do it they don't [__]
around no more on planes they're not
[__] around no more have you had
anyone lose it on a plane I had a friend
of mine lose it at an airport one day
he's not allowed to fly in that terminal
or Airline no more oh God cuz he was
late and they closed the [__] plane
on him and it was his fault and he got
mad and kicked the [__] counter done
you're not even allowed to you're not
even allowed in one of those terminals
they told him he can never fly Delta
again or be in one of those [__]
terminals
[__] this
was I think it was he was after 911 it
was like 2005 when it happened you know
we were talking
about Futures and being young and we've
been talking a lot about that Sunday and
uh we stayed after the podcast till
about 1: in the morning and we're just
talking about life and
generalities you know I'm 53 and uh Le's
28 it's a
big age Gap and it's funny hanging out
with Lee over the last few years doing a
podcast I'm coming over whatever you
know it makes me think a lot and in the
process of writing a book and when I
write the book sometimes and I go back
and read these things I compare them
like my life to Le you know and I Jesus
Christ so I was telling Lee a week ago
you know if I had a chance to do it all
over
again once I hit 28 I would make a
decision to become a millionaire by the
time I was 40 now you people going to
say why 40 because when I say A
Millionaire I say somebody who's well
off not comfortable and not a
millionaire but somebody who's taken
care of in every base what's the best
way to be taken care of when you're 38
to 40 join the service when you're 18 do
20 years come out when you're 38 you got
you got full insurance full benefits you
go back to school and you have a thing
called the pension and those pensions
don't [__] around those pensions pay you
some [__] money every month so even
if you get a part-time gig doing
security work at high pay you're not
doing that bad I think you get like cuz
my cousins are both in the Air Force I
think you get like something like
75% and then they they both bought
houses at like the same age I am like
nice houses but they have the option to
just live on base and just as far as I
as far as I understand take that money
for 20 years of no bills that like I
wish like when I I was 18 I was even
nerdier and geekier now so that wasn't
even an option but it's funny about 28
like you said it's like the first time
I've really started thinking about my AG
28 is the 28 and 20 26 through 2
28 is when you've already been
brokenhearted you already went to
college the job you wanted you didn't
get you already you know it took you a
while to get get a job maybe you got a
job uh now you're paying back
loans and you find yourself working
ironing a shirt every night you know
living with three guys you know drinking
and all sudden you're like at the end of
the week I got no money so you start
thinking about your life you go what the
[__] happened one minute I was
graduating college and the next minute
I'm living with three [__] guys I'm
broke they're [__] muts you know it
it's a line from a a comedy album
but around this time is when you figure
out like your dreams aren't going to
come true like you realize like oh like
they might not come true which is just
it's weird that's why the girl that
won't suck your dick when you're 20 or
maybe come around when she's 34 because
she's already had crabs the the GU
cheated on her you know you got a job
and a heartbeat and a license you're
[__] solid compared to the guy she's
been with and remember when she was 21
she was the queen of the [__] prom
and she had plans and future so yeah it
happens to all of us like that it we
start lowering our standards but at the
same time listen man I didn't take life
serious till I was
32 one day at 32 I found myself [__]
broke I mean living from [__] garbage
can to mouth pretty much you know had a
refrigerator only had Snapple in it and
beer never was there food in that
[__] thing I lived in a one-bedroom
pretty much studio apartment I had had a
TV I had
cable but I was living like Rocky b ball
which there's nothing wrong like that
but they didn't put you on this planet
just to give up right I love to just get
by if I was by my own if I was on my own
I'd live in this office I've told you
that a thousand times already I live in
this office I keep this refrigerator you
teach me how to get Netflix on the
computer and the apps to watch the news
and [__] like that I wouldn't go any 400
bucks whatever uh a car payment of three
your
insurance that's it I'm getting by that
means I can get deliver pizza one night
a week that means I could do I could do
anything three days a week and make my
nut and not worry about life how and not
be responsible great way to live I did
it for a [__] long time we've spoken
about that guy the homeless man who
won't take your money right how many
homeless people do think are just like
they're just like I'm just I'm just
going to enjoy my life from now on who
cares that's it they're comfortable
where there and listen that homeless guy
made his decision when I see him over
there and I try to offer him money and I
bring him food and I haven't seen him in
a while I drive in that neighborhood all
the [__] time I think he went I think
the cops chased him out of over there
[__] I don't see him over there at all
maybe the last 6 months but all that
time I realized something in my
conversations with him that that was his
choice he wanted to be there okay and
we're all at one point see I got married
and at at one time I said this is just
too much this is just too much to handle
as a as a human being cuz it was a weak
[__] and I was like I can't handle this
I just want to disappear I want to live
like John Rambo work at a car wash three
days a week have a little apartment eat
can [__] but one day man you go you know
what I got friends they got wives they
got houses they got cars and they got
lives how do I get a [__]
life it took me to be 32 now at 32 I had
a life when she walked out of that house
Lee I had a life wasn't the best quality
life I was taking care of myself I was
eating good I was exercising I was
making money I would always take some
type of
class but I was just sailing
along I was just waiting to [__] hit
something I knew this was not going to
be
forever I knew it I [__] knew it I'm
like this is not going to be forever
there's no way I'm gonna be 40 and
that's theate rules with a truck and
come home and play with my kid for two
hours and then on Saturdays and Sundays
I got the [__] weekend off Saturdays
I watch the kid and Sundays I go to the
In-laws for dinner this is
it this is
it I did time I was a loser all those
years I was in a rocket ship I stole I
turn my life around for this [__]
boredom
it was boring to me I was like I can't I
can't I need something else so for like
the I don't know let's say 70% of
Americans who live that life roughly
maybe it's 50/50 who knows are they are
they lying to themselves are they really
not happy not at all not at all not at
all well we had a discussion earlier
about
people we have a
friend that uh paid their dues for
something for a few years and we were
talking earlier we don't think that
he understands what he got himself into
absolutely you know and that's the first
time I mentioned it to Lee Lee hadn't
mentioned it to me once before but I
never saw it but from Lee and I's
conversation the
night guess how many people that happens
to when you're 18 do you think you could
really make a quality decision about
what you want to
be I thought I could I thought I did in
your head what is the percentage you
think of people that ate went to college
with an idea what they wanted to be and
that's what they're doing
today today maybe like 20% I think is
that how low it is I think it's low I
and because that's the question is like
is what if they went to school for
there's a lot of people who aren't are
doing even if it's a good job maybe they
went to school for history and now
they're I don't know like a a marketing
person like there I think there's a lot
of people who change isn't isn't it like
most people have three to five careers
isn't that what the stat like is that
what it is I I'll look it up or
something real quick but it's something
like people how many of you had you've
had multiple yeah but I'm a loser I
didn't have multiple careers cuz I was a
winner I had multiple careers cuz I was
a loser first of all I didn't know what
I wanted to do right second of all I was
always buying time cuz something was
coming or at least I thought something
was just going to bump into like I was
going to pick up Sylvester Stallone
driving a limo he's going to put me in a
movie or I didn't [__] know that's
the pipe dream I had okay so I had a
bunch of jobs cuz
number one I was lazy number two I
thought they were going to hand it to me
and they're not going to hand it to you
so I did the easy way out I became a
[__] Petty
thief and then in the meantime Petty
thiefing when I get sick and tired of
petty thiefing and turn my life around I
get a job at a place as a cook I'll be a
bartender in a year after two weeks I go
are you [__] crazy Jes are you
[__] crazy because of the work to put
in that you have to put into it sure
because the who wants to put work in how
can I come to you and go in 10 years
you're going to be a great comedian Lee
you're going to go okay so if I get on
stage tomorrow January
11th you what you mean to tell me is is
in what is it
2027 I'm going to be a good
comedian I can't even think that [__]
far and I'm F 50 and I've done gone
through
it so I can't imagine a 28- year old
wrapping their [__] head about around
that
when I was 32 late I was out of
options okay so I had no reason when I
was 32 I was out of
options I had nothing when I tell you
nothing going for
me so I had two ideas I had one I could
try this comedy
[__] and when I first started comedy
remember I started comedy in 91 and I
was like uh listen this is going to
happen I'm not going to do what Lee does
Lee's an [__] he gets on stage every
night he's a [__] [__] I'm just as
funny as Lee is Lee's been doing comedy
four years I could ripe my feet but this
is my thinking my thinking was that I
was going to be in a comedy club and
Jerry Lewis was going to see me and put
me in a
movie that's what I really thought like
that was how delusional the Coke and
life and [__] you know this is way
before Kim kadashian but there was
somebody who was Kim kadashian at that
time who had me confused that I was
going to just get on stage one day and
Allan king or David Letterman or
somebody was going to be in the audience
walking through and they were going to
see me and put me on their show and I'd
be a famous standup comic I had no idea
the work that went into it would you
daydream about it oh
absolutely like this is all going to be
differently don't worry about this give
me 20 bucks come on listen when [__]
and they see me at that comedy club in
two weeks you're going to be begging you
gave me more
money you know like that was my [__]
honest you know I get and I'd fuel that
dream with cocaine and actually [__]
buy it like the [__] that we are at
that age and when your mind is that
thwarted so I started in July 91 it took
me till September of 93 to realize that
that pipe dream was never going to
happen never have and that's not even
that I bet there's people who smoke the
pipe a little bit longer than you did
that's only two years and I buckled down
and I said you know what if I'm going to
do this I have to do this right and I
put together a plan and I went back to
Colorado and all the plans worked out
except for me being a parent okay no
worries but even throughout that whole
down ship and the state of mind I was in
I kept getting on stage I kept getting
on stage it didn't matter I kept getting
on stage who gives a [__] keep getting
on stage you're in pain you're mad get
on stage talk about it on stage and
that's what I did and by 94 which was
two years later than that I really had a
dream not to be famous or nothing like
that at this point I just wanted to be a
working comic that nobody knew
about I would go and do triple runs and
and and you know whatever the company in
Iowa and I would work for
creative and I would just travel around
the country in a car and do comedy I was
pretty much set with that never did I
think about millions of dollars never
did I you never you never would like sit
in bed at night be like oh I can't wait
talk what esteem that I have to actually
say to myself not in 1991 when I was
delusional once I knew what you had to
put into comedy and what went into it
and the work and
everything there was no way I thought
about Millions I thought about being a
break even working comic and I was fine
with that you know why because where I
came
from the position I came
from that would have just turned my life
around if I could just be a working
comic and stop stealing and doing
drugs I'd be okay when I say stealing I
mean generalities people just doing
stupid [__] I'm not saying stealing I'm
talking about stealing [__] time and
and whatever from yourself stupid [__]
uh lee comes to me and says hey
I got five rims give me 10 bucks we're
going to go sell them and make 50 stupid
[__] then we get there and the guy don't
give us a deposit with the check
balances kid [__] kid [__] that we
didn't think out that's what I mean by
stealing not you know Burger once I
started once 95 came I wasn't doing none
of that [__] I was just [__] doing
comedy if you had an eight ball to sell
I'd sell it for you that type of [__]
you know well it must be hard was it I
mean was it hard for you to like stop
looking for okay here there's the next
drug deal there's the next oh I could
steal that and then I can make like to
turn that off that mechanism off in your
brain just because you learn you you've
worked that muscle the same way you
worked Jitsu okay when I got the longest
yard even at that point if you come to
me and say I need an eightball I'd sell
it to
you you want me to [__] you and tell
you I went drug no in 204 you came to me
and said I need to buy a quarter o of
coke and I knew you I got to take it to
my brother he's visiting out here from
Boston and the guy he worked for wants a
half ounce of coke oh and a heartbeat
that's 200 in my pocket and a grandma
blow why wouldn't that's three bills for
just taking a
ride but when I stopped doing
coke it was the funniest thing 3 months
later people were coming to me with
cash like people always thought I was
shake shake what's that word Shady Shady
so they would always like I'll give you
half that hour and a half when you come
back that type of [__] or you know it
was always one of those things when I
stopped doing coke 90 days later I never
forget one day sitting in the park lot
at the comedy store I went there to do
comedy obviously and somebody came up to
me somebody I know well for a long time
and in their hand they probably had a
th000 bucks and they said to me can you
get me this much coke the next three
days I have relatives in town 10 years
ago I would have taken that [__]
money
told him to meet him there tomorrow at 6
and next thing I would have had a sudden
gig in
Pittsburgh and I would give him the
money in a week and I no blow that's the
type of guy I was I give you the money
back but there was going to be a couple
days where I disappeared I don't know
what happened my phone got lost the
pager got swallowed by the parrot you
know I was one of those dudes you got
your money I always gave everybody their
money back you know or I give them the
coke back and take a big chunk of Co
Coke out of it and they call me and go
Joey what is this oh that's the way the
guy gave it to me well I got to give it
back to the guy I can't give it back to
the guy the guy went back to Vegas you
if you want we drive to Vegas now the
kid stuck with it I would do something
shitty that way it stress you out when
people were like where's my money
where's my Coke like oh look at me do I
look stressed out no no towards the end
I didn't give a
[__]
from I didn't give a [__] for a long
time like after I got divorced I told
you I bumped into that dude that gave me
the 2 lbs for the the the $88,000 that
time and I had another guy that gave me
membership for the mafia he gave me
money and I signed him up to I gave him
an
application and I told him what a mail I
mean this is the dumbest thing ever you
know that kid was calling me till about
5 years ago hey I live in San Jose I
never heard from those people but I did
give you two grand I don't know what
happened listen meet me I'll call you
when I get the s was
that and I never call
him that's how crazy I was I used to
hang out with this dude Mike
runny and I learned when when my mother
died I started hanging out with him like
in
1980 and from 80 to 80 [__] three it
was an
education because he really didn't give
a
[__] he would walk behind the store take
cigarettes and walk out of the store
right in front of you it was our friend
Store look back not not even acknowledge
Him and my friend pulled me over and his
brother and said B what's up with Mike
run he just comes in here takes
cigarettes and walks
out there's some people in life that
don't [__] give a [__] I'm so jealous
of that I'll never forget him betting
with a bookie losing and saying [__]
that guy and the guy saying come on I'm
gonna beat you up come over here and
beat me up [__] you and your [__]
$300 bet
[__] you [__] you and I learned a ton
from him cuz those fucku work from time
to time you got to tell somebody go [__]
thems from time to time so they work
towards the there's a story one time I
was in Seattle I was living in an office
above uh Josh Wolf's bar Josh Wolf had a
lobo
Loco and this is
1996 and what I would do is I would find
grapes in those days I had a sports
betting service I got this [__] phone
company to give me credit with no
deposit they gave me an 800 number and a
phone line with I don't know how
unlimited 10 minutes 10 cents a minute I
don't know what this company or who they
came from I've never heard from them
again this is 1996 this new cell company
or do you think there's like a $10,000
bill somewhere oh
oh so I had a 1 1800 number so you could
call me and then I had two different
numbers to call out and what I would do
is I had a guy in San Diego that had a
huge sports betting
company but he only signed you for the
season okay a lot of people like why am
I going to pay you 3,000 for the season
what if you suck the first month and I'm
stuck with you that's why I come in I
would he give me your name and I call
you and go Lisa at Pete labomba here you
know Pete laboma is not really Pete but
I'm not I don't I don't have time right
now Pete listen shut the [__] up I got
your name and number from my friend he
says you want to roll for the year I
don't want to sign people for the year
the type of player I am in one [__]
month you're going to get so much money
you're not even you're not even going to
want to know me no more but I can't I
got a lot of customers and I'd make up
some cockamamy story and how I'm going
to sign him for for a month
$2,250 for the [__]
month unlimited if whatever I get you
get if I get Chinese ping pong if I get
two [__] goldfish to the wrestling in
a park in [__] Chicago you're going
to get the the winner of that [__]
hat and I'd sign him for the
month for unlimited picks unlimited
picks and I'd give him three picks a
week tops they' be calling me for seven
[__] you three we're going to make money
I'm going to give you one on Saturday
one early and then the winner of the
Sunday night game or the total do you
have any sources or were you just
picking them for yourself I had some
sources but I was picking them myself I
knew some of the football players and
the Seahawks and I'd ask them creepy
questions well what are you ask them
like who's looking good at practice I
ask him you know when you played against
these guys how was the defense that they
hit hard what do you think you know
stupid thing not enough to make you bet
money on it to be hon is that if that's
what you're asking
that's just like yeah I like I just I
never I I wouldn't even know every time
we talk about this sports betting I
can't imagine I can't believe you got
people to pay just for like your what
you think is going to happen well at
this time yeah but when I worked for a
service they had real information they
would have people and Reps and [__] like
that oh really so they would actually
yeah they they the reason why you paid
them is because when I worked for the
big company I worked for he had people
wow he coaches and different players and
uh you know he just had people it was
they they had a I forget what college it
was for but like two or three weeks ago
they had an assistant coach who wasn't
even at the school anymore I think it
was uh what's the one in in Texas it's D
whatever it is I think I think like he
was giving offensive game plans to other
coaches it was I can't it's
crazy and that's it that's all you need
so I wouldn't I didn't know those type
of people I knew the type of people that
would tell you that the quarterback's
knee's [__]
up there's no injury report on
it oh so if he gets hit once or twice
it's going to be bad you know he's not
going to be able to throw that far like
different things that you knew that
nobody else knew and then during the
game you look like a hero oh yeah his
knee hurt hot what I tell you is Nega
you follow me that's the information
that impresses people he was out on
night his his his God forbid his uh
somebody he knows got hit by a [__]
train his mind's not been there for the
last week that type of [__] I know it's
not available anymore but was numbers
just the easiest thing in the world cuz
you didn't have to have any it was just
taking numbers you were literally just
writing numbers down yeah that's it
numbers are still available but it's a
oneman
operation and it's got to be an ethnic
neighborhood oh you think they still do
it yeah yeah they still do it I know for
a fact they still do it if there's
numbers and people have dreams it's a
great racket the only that replaced the
only thing that [__] it up was you
know when the lotos and stuff came in
but back to the story I was telling you
so I'm living in this office I'm
probably pulling
down 800 a week on this little scam I
got upstairs which ain't bad people
sending me money to a Western Union and
then I would get you to go up there or I
would pick the money up you could only
go to West India a few times under your
name so I would go one time I'd pay you
100 to go with me I give Josh Wolf 100
to go with me Gavin 100 to go with me
Brody 100 to go with me and I'd send the
money to their name oh [__] pick it up
for me and just give me the money at the
comedy club later there's one right here
I knew all the Western
Unions I knew where they all
were [__] so is that what they I never
knew what Western Unions were for I
never knew had anyone had to buy money
you send it to me on PayPal yeah oh
Jesus I don't even have to go to Western
Union now you want the information give
me your PayPal account send me 300 right
now on
PayPal that's
it that's it so I got this guy here is
where it gets
ugly I was making money off guys calling
them up like I would be on the road and
on Sunday mornings I have to get up
early and call people on a dime on a pay
phone with [__] quarters cuz I was on
the road I didn't have my 800 l
I'd have to call people and go hey Pete
what's going on listen Joey I'm on the
[__] road I'm on my way to Chicago
I'm sitting in the [__] box with the
owner like I just [__] and really
you're doing comedy and [__] Portland
Oregon in a [__] hotel and I hear a
woman getting beat next to me and [__]
and I could smell her hair on fire and
I'm telling this guy on the phone I'm in
the [__] Ritz I got a butler his name
is Charles he's massaging my anus you
know [__] like like that meanwhile I'm
in this [__] dump and I'd say you
know i' sent you the information I'd
have him Western you me more money I'd
have people pick it up for me I'd call
Brody wherever where you at picked up
that money I'll see you Monday night at
the [__] comedy club and then I would
dispatch my my games but anyway I'm in a
bar one night and I started talking to
this guy and we're talking back and
forth next time we have Josh on he'll
tell you I think we discussed it one
time and we're talking about sports Papa
and the guy goes I don't have a
bookmaker I go well it's your lucky day
I got a
bookmaker and I did this for years I did
this with uh with my ex drug dealer oh
no yeah I used to do this all the time I
just call you out and put a bug in your
ear but with this guy he I told him I I
get I could call him Betsy and after a
few weeks I'll introduce you to the
bookmaker this guy was the kiss of death
he was giving me 1,000 to, 1500 every
week and sometimes I wouldn't take his
action so sometimes he' call me if I
didn't like the game I go listen he's at
a [__] game [__] I want to get the
next day he'd called me mad God damn it
I knew I could then when he'd call me
and if I like the game in fact he'd call
me first and if I like let's say Dallas
and they were playing the uh who's
Dallas playing next week
uh the Kansas are they playing Kansas
City no Kansas C's AFC team Dallas is n
Dallas is playing Green Bay oh you're
right I got him in this [__] room and
you're the sports guy uh let's say
Dallas is playing Green Bay next week
Dallas I don't know if Dallas I don't I
don't know what this I'm just making
this up let's say Dallas is playing
Green Bay in Dallas and Dallas is giv
Four Points I love Dallas I would when
he called me and asked me who I liked
I'd pitch from Green Bay oh yeah Green
Bay is tough in fact I'm going to bet a
thousand on Green Bay myself were you
ever give a winner just so he would like
keep doing it with you no no he lost for
three week he would pick a winner but by
that time he'd beat down 900 and he win
400 he still owed me the juice and the
original
$50 so I would get I was getting them
every week finally me and me and Josh
are going to Moscow Idaho we're leaving
and I got to meet this guy this guy was
my gas
money this guy was my guas money we had
no money the plan was to meet him we're
going to go have a big Hardy lunch on
Uncle Joey and fill that tank up and get
a bag of weed to drive to go like
doctors
we get down there I go to collect from
the gun guy's like no I'm not giving you
the money this is like the fifth time in
a row I paid you and I still haven't met
the mob guy and I'm like listen he don't
want to meet nobody right now I need
this [__] Loot and we argued for 20
minutes on the street he was yelling at
me I'm not giving it to I said I'm not
going to argue with you no more either
you give me the money or you can't put
no more bets in and by two weeks you're
going to get a knockout on your door and
I'm not threatening you I'm just telling
you what it is with these people I did
you a favor now you're going to do this
to me now I got to go pay the [__]
1200 Fe and I walked in the bar and 3
minutes later he came in okay I'll give
you the money but next week I want to
meet the
guy and that was the last bet I took
from him absolutely
oh that that's when you know to take
youres that was it and by the way the
the line on Dallas is Dallas minus 4 who
the [__] you think he deal with God damn
it at home yeah in Dallas yeah and I
didn't even know that I just took a
[__] lucky
bet God damn it and R almost
quarterbacking is he really I don't know
I don't think
say I'm just [__] saying here but
that's that was the mentality even then
like once I when I got to Seattle I was
already on a roll like I was already
making moves I was making moves I wasn't
making in Boulder because I was focusing
so much on what was going on with my
child and the divorce that I couldn't do
anything creativity or sometimes you
have all your energy in that and that's
what we were talking about the other day
today I go even sometimes when you have
a girlfriend the first year I get it I
get it man I understand
love you know I fell in love various
times in my life but the last time I
fell in love was the only way I played
the card right and that's why I'm still
with it 16
years I play it to the tea I didn't give
in in the beginning I stuck to my guns
I'm a comedian this is what I do there's
no Christmas Eve I'm working you know
New Year's I do a comedy show this is
what I do on your birthday guess what
this is what I do on my birthday there's
no vac you know I I I made this from the
beginning so there was no lying I always
got burnt because I'm like everybody
else when a girl tells you you know I
love cancer and and muffins me too as
long as you give me that [__] I love
what you love we [__] just talk [__]
to to to to get into her pants and then
once after we get into her pants we have
to tell the truth yeah when or you have
to say go home or listen I got to do
[__] you know and that's where it bites
you in the ass later on but it also
bites you in the ass with relationships
it bites you in the ass with friendships
and we're really bunching the assw is
what we learned today business 100%
business business you know today some
guy hit me up from a Subaru dealer
really good guy talks to me on Facebook
from time to time you know and I've
always told people that I worked with a
lot of car dealers and I worked with a
lot of great salesmen okay but there was
one guy sold with that was a
psychological
salesman and he had a deal and he goes
every time you do this you will sell a
car I
get 90% of the time if you do it this
way
you will sell a car until this day I
believe it and the reason why I do not
believe in giving away free tickets to
comedy shows at all at all is the same
reason 10 years ago I can not sell this
reason but today I can why couldn't you
sell it because all I had was my standup
to
offer now when you come watch me you pay
for the you pay for the standup the
videos with JRE you know all that stuff
this is the payoff from all that stuff
are you with me kind of sort of here
yeah all the all those years of work
where maybe you didn't get paid for it
or you got 20 because I didn't know any
work around standup okay now we give you
free content you know there's the
YouTube videos all this [__] is just us
[__] around I don't think of money or
nothing when I started doing this [__] I
didn't think of money or nothing it was
just to get ourselves out there so
people would come to the [__]
shows you're I think that's a you're
paying for experience you're paying for
the years of open mics that's and that's
why some people like well I could do
this for half the money like yeah you
could you could get a comedian for a
show for a 100 bucks but it's not going
to be as good as the comedian for 500
who's not going to be it's it's crazy
people always want to nickel and on you
but if you're really paying for
experience well and a lot of and but
that's what you know we would talking
about today you were talking about a
certain situation that there was no
deposit
taken and I tell people all the time the
deposit and I didn't write this I didn't
invent this I just learned this through
the car business that that guy Ry
Pressler God bless his soul wherever he
is one of my all-time favorite Jews he
turned me into not a car salesman but a
Salesman he really did it's like
tomorrow it's going to be a year that I
walked into Alberto crane school
and it's one of the best things I ever
did for myself in my
life I'm not a world champion Jiu-Jitsu
guy I'm not going to the pan Americans I
I don't I get beat up by Blue belts and
I am a blue belt but the commitment just
that I kept going and all that [__] I
like that I can't wait for it for two
years to tell you guys I've been there
for two years because even at this age
you have to stick to something you know
I wanted to talk to you about this about
control factors that you think I'm crazy
I know that you go home at night and
talk to Paul and go Joey di is crazy and
I know that people have mentioned it to
me but I want to tell you where it came
from I had I couldn't I didn't have
control of drugs over me and I didn't
have control of me
stealing but I was a [__] thief and
all that and I had no control over my
drug habit and I had no control over
myself so I found different ways to
control myself you know I didn't get get
fat till I got
older when I was younger all those years
that was my control to the te when I
told you I would eat a can of tuna fish
with salt and pepper I ate a can of tuna
fish with salt and [__]
pepper one summer I somebody said to me
dog you got heavy I didn't get heavy I
just gained weight I took that so
personally for a summer I ate tuna out
of a [__] can and American cheese and
a protein shake every [__] day why do
you think that is part of your life like
you can be so disciplined but in other
parts you can't control you know I
didn't believe in letting everything go
out of control okay so the drug is out
of control and there's nothing I have
$100 in my pocket and I have $200 in
that table for rent I could snort the
$100 I would snort all
$300 there was no
control there was a club when I was
growing up called
quintessence this is when I started my
little
stupidity I started my little stupidity
like in high school on Friday nights I
wouldn't go out some nights and it would
drive my friends crazy as a
discipline I would not go
out to punish
myself everything everything in the
world I would not go
up just to prove to myself that I had
control in some
areas then this club opened up called
quintessence and all my friends would go
up there and they would all come back
with the same stories every [__]
night by this time it was
1983 882 I never walked into
contestants I didn't give a [__] if
eight of my best friends were going I
would refuse to go up
there and I never went up there and that
was the discipline that was the only
part of my life I had discipline over
was it like was it did you not go out to
not do the drugs because
no I CU I could do drugs on Saturday
night some nights I just stayed in and
did drugs now I can't lie to you and
tell you I wasn't doing drugs I would
just stay in with a grma Coke do it by
myself so what was the point of of
proving this to yourself if it's like
the least bad thing that I wouldn't go
in there that I wouldn't go in there
that's why when I say to you I won't eat
Chinese until I go to New York and you
look at me like right yeah I stick to it
when I tell you I won't eat no other
pizza but that Joe's I'll eat a slice or
two as maintenance until I get to New
York next year you think I'm good you
know I'm right no I know you're right
but here's the thing it's like it it's
just it seems like you pick it randomly
it's like okay I'm going to be really
strict but [__] Ranch [__] like all like
it just seems like you have like really
weird sticks in the sand and I
understand them like when you explain it
to me I get it but it's just like why
does he care about Cuban St like why
like I don't know I'm trying to blanking
why does he care about uh Donuts why
does he care about where I get my Donuts
so what does he care about where I get
my pizza like who gives this [__]
because I always want you to get the
best yeah but then you say you want to
live in the office then you say you at
that point in my life okay listen when
I'm living in this office if I'm if I'm
going for 900 a month guess what I think
I'll be eating some Subway sandwiches
right okay which I did when I first
started comedy I ate more veggie cheese
sandwiches than you ever dreamed of I
would never eat those [__] nasty Coke
cuts but I would inhale those veggie
cheese sandwiches on the road one half
one 6 in for lunch and the other 6 in
for dinner that's what you got to do
that's you got to do those chips I'd
steal a bag of chips on the way out I'd
[__] drink so much Mountain Dew in
those Subway sandwiches Mountain Dew
would be [__] coming out of my
eyballs
because that's what you have to do if
I'm living here you don't think I'm
going to be getting the pizza from 711
at 1:00 in at night when I walk down
there hungry as a [__] and that
bad Pizza starred me in the face because
if I'm living here if you're walking on
ice you might as well dance I might as
well I still would need ranch dressing I
still wouldn't do a lot of things but I
think I would eat one of those pizzas
because that's a situation I put myself
in that's a that's a situation I
accepted to be
in okay so it it upsets you because I
have the means to not eat Subway or like
like why are you doing this to yourself
if you can afford the extra three bucks
for a nice sandwich it's not your
lifestyle it's like you live in a
one-bedroom apartment you live so very
nice you're neat and all a sudden you
got this disgusting [__] pizza and
disgusting wings at your house that you
look at the wing and they're [__]
like gray like it's an old chicken that
got stabbed or some [__] yeah I don't
know that's and I I think a lot of
people do it like they they sabotage
themselves in a weird way like they'll
they'll work hard for other people but
when it comes to themselves they won't
work out or they won't work on their
business it's uh I don't understand why
that procrastination I every year I read
that the war of art every year by Steven
prfi every year I read that in January
just to give me a little boost and again
you know it's
procrastination you know and and I can't
use it more than the word of writing
when you first move here and you want to
be a writer you go to Samuel French and
you buy every book in there and you read
half of it and and then you go [__] I'm
not a writer because the only way you
can learn how to write is to write is to
get down every day and write for [__]
6 hours and it comes together eventually
you know for a year I wrote shitty blogs
with wrong spelling and bad
pronunciation but I learned how to write
again I mean you know I was a comic I
didn't know how to write a [__] blog
I don't know how to [__] write a [__]
I know I forgot about couldn't and
wouldn't and I forgot about you and your
I forgot about all that [__] I've been
writing jokes in a car on a piece of
[__] paper with a pen what do I know
about you and yours and [__] this and
that but then why did you keep doing it
like that's where that's where I think
the difference is is that you kept doing
it and I'm seeing that I never stuck to
nothing Lee I was the kid that stuck to
one thing in his life from the age of
six to the age of 14 I went to karate
religious ly until to the age of 15
maybe even no 16 till my mother died
that long wow that year I went to karate
religiously except when those three
years I went to Catholic school I would
only go on Saturdays but I'd stay the
whole day like I'd go with 10 and stay
for the kid class the the other kid
class The Adult class and the sparring
class like I wouldn't get home till four
and then from there we go into New York
City to Honda and we'd buy [__]
swords and new chunks and stars and I
get a new ghee that's what I did on
Saturdays when I went to Catholic school
Friday night I went to the movies
Saturday night I spent it with my family
eating dinner talking at the bar and
Sunday I had breakfast with my family
din lunch with my family and I go to
school and that's the only thing you
stuck with is martial arts martial arts
once I quit martial arts the only thing
I stuck with was
drugs for 27 [__] years I stuck it
out with drugs [__] up thing I didn't
join science ology for 27 years I did
drugs for 27 [__] years then realize
that was a [__] wrong
turn
Okay 27
years and then in all my [__]
stupidity I got into comedy and I knew I
had to St stick with it because I had
nothing else nothing else and who wants
to be [__] 40 with nothing else in
their [__]
life at the age of 40 okay was I
successful or anything not at all I'm
still not [__] successful let me tell
you what I was at the age of [__]
40 I've been on Mad TV
maybe I'd shot a pilot for
CBS
I did
basball I was featuring and
co-headlining but I still had no [__]
self-esteem I mean I still was doing
[__] drugs so none of that [__]
mattered as a kid so at 40 I did have a
direction you had a direction is what
I'm trying to say I had a direction now
was up to me to take it levely levels
levels but that's in my in my head at 40
I when I let me just put you at 18 by 40
I'm running a I'm I'm a CEO I have a
mansion like I think I think 40 is like
you're basically done like at 18 that's
what I thought now 40 is only 12 years
away I'm like oh [__] cuz what we're
were talking about at the beginning just
going back it says people change every
five to seven years careers right right
now but is it an upswing careers or is
it a downswing in not necessarily it
could actually it's uh Robert Jer had
that movie a couple years ago I didn't
see like the intern it says that you
should have um you should have money
saved up like this is an article about
changing careers you should have a money
saved up for the training period which
is it could be actually training or it
could just be the first three years of
anything where you're not making three
to four years you're not making dick and
that's and that's [__] up because all
right let's say I've thought about this
before let's say it's 3 to four years to
build up then you have 3 to four years
of doing good and then what you get sick
of it and and then you start again that
you 3 to four years to make your okay so
let's eliminate that okay okay so I did
all that [__] early correct right I did
all that [__]
early and by the time 1995 came okay at
the age of 32 I knew exactly what I
wanted to go for let's get something
straight wanted to go for big difference
than anything else at that time I was
not thinking of movies or TV I knew that
that was just a [__] pipe dream I
thought that even if I came to La if I
even came to La I'd just end up a
[__]
extra okay maybe if I was [__] lucky
but by the age of 40 now at least I had
a direction was I going to be Louis CK
was I going to be Kevin Hart not at all
but I knew one thing at 40 I could make
a living I was in the Union now I was
going to get a
pension and I had
insurance and for a guy like
me that pulled his own teeth out with a
wrench I never thought I'd had any of
these [__]
things
wow so and so you you're content with
your life at
40 no no no but I knew I was on the
right
direction satisfaction is a complete
different
thing how long did it take you to get to
you are you at
satisfaction yes and no [__] the
satisfaction was that I made the right
choice that at least I stuck with it do
you know what I'm saying that's the
satisfaction of it that
uh I did something you didn't quit you
you have a full career in comedy Now
so the other career I I picked up at
this age was Jiu-Jitsu and it's not a
career I just go to it the first two
years at vmac and at hegan Machado was
my first two years of Comedy flip flab I
do it a week here I'll take this week
off my body needs to rebuild who the
[__] are you what are you Steve Austin
suddenly you know what your body needs
yeah no when I made the constant
decision of what I wanted to do when you
threw me on my back that day and your
gee ripped and I was wrestling in there
with [__] the old guy Nick and uh
John Bud and I was still breathing heavy
and I was still getting stuck in stupid
positions I said this is it I got to get
into a program like cuz I'm an anal type
of dude I want to do this right and I
just so happened to look on the web page
and they had a fundamental class and
that's exactly what I needed I needed
fundamentals like in stand up you need I
[__] around for two years now I I
understood what they were saying okay
you got to write jokes you got to write
jokes you could improvise here but you
got to write jokes here you could do
this here but you know and that's what
happened this year did I improve that
much in this year my breathing out a
little better I'm a little bit more
comfortable on my back am I a world
champion no but I know even if it takes
me eight years to put all the pieces
together I know that the Pieces come
together and that's one of the many
reasons I do this podcast when I first
started doing this podcast I did not
think we would get to these Heights or
we would be at this getting downloads or
whatever I did this podcast to let
everybody
know that you could get there it's all
[__] that they feed you you could
get there if you really
wanted if you really [__] wanted so
Lee and I started talking [__] Sunday
night we're both high as [__] and we're
babbling here and we're talking about
being 28 again and what things you would
do what would I do differently I would
have never gotten married I would have
used this now you got to remember if I'm
28 now okay I'd used that tnder app and
I wouldn't stop till I got VD and Gara
and pimples on my face or whatever I
don't know that's why they invented that
app guys so you don't need to get
married everybody's in everybody knows
what time it is I'm going to meet you
you're going to meet me we're going to
do some jumping jacks and then I'm going
back to my life and you're going back to
your [__] life and we won't tell
nobody okay and I would take four years
like Lee said which would be a
transition period what would the
transition period be a transition period
is you take a look at your bills you
really take a look at your bills and you
go what can I live without that
underwear never again bro you i' I I
haven't had cable in a year and a half
and I'm the biggest TV ner in the world
you look at your schedule and you go
what do yeah I uh what do I need no no
even even you even a guy like you right
now if you came to me tomorrow guard
let's take the Volkswagon back let's go
get a seven-year car with no payment you
know insurance is paid for it's a solid
car it's checked out it's got low
mileage you're going to drive an
import it's not going to blow
up okay it's not going to have a nice
leather sheet the bedroom you got we're
going to move that same bedroom up to
[__] Tarzana and make it a studio and
make it a studio you know what I'm
saying you're going to get your computer
blah blah blah I mean that's and you
look at that right there boom you
already but Joey the gas well we're
going to figure something out for the
gas too we're going to get open mics
around there for your gas you know you
cut all that [__] needs to cut that's
the fouryear transition and I'm seeing a
similar thing with uh opening an office
or starting a business there's all these
things out there that you can spend
money on hiring a CPA getting a nice
bigger office getting the nicer
Furniture I I learned from you this year
I got a uh a computer chair for my house
I went to that uh secondhand office
furniture place I was like why am I
going to pay for a brand new chair when
I can get one for 40 bucks for that's
just as good and then but it that's your
first and my at least my first impulse
is always to get spend more money pay my
way out of the issue
I mean I'm no [__] business Mogul
here a couple years ago Lee calls me up
there's an office in Facebook it's uh
$1,200 up in uh [__] uh van eyes it
had a view of
Gelson's it had a balcony it had a
smoking room it had a visitor's room and
I looked at Lee and I go Lee this is
nice but it's a g note Laro we still got
to pay for for commercial [__] uh
internet tables this that this and we
could and we ended up in one office that
was a dump we got evicted from there but
look it CAU us two years and we get in a
nice [__] office we pay a nice rent
in here you know we got to pay the
commercial internet there's nothing you
can do you can't beat those
[__] and uh it's a business it's
become a little business for us you know
but I could have exuberant C ceras and a
and a and a and a [__] team of
producers publicist and a team of
producers and and what' you get what'
you get what'd you get you got nothing
these people love to you know when you
see a movie and it cost 75 million to
make did they tell you about the lobster
Tales they bought on that set and the
and the people who are making $22 an
hour holding a [__] wire did they
tell you about those guys that's you
don't that same movie you can make that
movie for [__] a million dollars you
can make that movie for 3/4 of a million
dollar and what the studio paid $30
million for but there's so much waste
you would sit there and die you would
sit there and [__] die how many times
have we had discussions and I start
cutting stuff off and you go but I don't
understand because you don't need it
it's not necessary I learned when I
became a comic when I became a comic I
shut everything down and got a page of
for whatever it was a month $7.95 a
month that was my nut when I first
started listening to you on podcast you
didn't have a cell phone really yeah on
with the very first Rogan I think they
talk about you getting your first cell
phone no I got my first cell phone in
2004 oh [__] okay 2003 when I first got
Spider-Man 2 yeah oh the must have been
the the set of Spider-Man 2 to Sprint
and they gave me a phone for $200 a
month that was my credit limit and if I
was 30 cents over they would shut my
[__] phone off Sprint oh God I
started with Sprint a long [__] time
ago with what do you mean I just got my
page but to get back to what we're
talking about it's so I think that a lot
like I see kids to now I talk to you
know CLE uh Theo 36 I mean he's got a
lot going on but even a kid like him
he's scared he told us on the show you
know he told us afterwards this is this
is [__] weird we're playing for
[__] keeps here you know and I really
don't think that when kids go to college
they know what they get themselves into
you said something at the beginning of
the podcast you know this is the year of
the podcast folks I don't know what to
tell you and I understand that you like
to do a
podcast uh you have something to
say we all have something to say so you
have something to say you're like [__]
it If Joey could do it Lee could do it
if [__] this moo could do it if this
moo could do it I want to start a
podcast right now Lee's getting calls
every other [__] day from eight
people a day that want to start a
podcast and they show up with these
exuberate demands that need Lee knows
it's not like well Joe Rogan's been
doing a podcast for eight years one of
the pioneers of podcast he comes to Lee
and says I want to do this podcast these
are limitations Lee knows that he could
cover the [__] spread but some guy
that's been an accountant and all of a
sudden wants to show up here and do a
podcast and do all these outlandish
things talk about football and flowers
and [__] veterinarians and all this
[__] it just doesn't uh so Lee has to
deal with this [__] I think it goes back
to what you were talking about earlier
expectations if you want to do a podcast
for you for the people who like what you
do but it's not going to people are are
contacting me and they're they don't
come out and say it but in reality what
they're saying is I want to be like
Rogan I I want to and that's great and
that's great but the reality is you have
to you have to it's not it's not going
to be as easy as just starting a podcast
you know what they sound like the people
who are like me in 91 who thought
thought that they were going to get on
stage one time and get discovered right
yeah that's the [__] up dream of
what's going on with podcasting right
now and listen I appreciate your dream
we all got to start with a dream but I
want your expectations to also be with
us I'm doing a podcast with a wrestler a
professional wrestler let's talk about
Opera no nobody wants to hear about
Opera from a [__] wrestler if you're
a wrestler they want to talk about your
experience the wrest I'm a comic a
criminal I did time I'm a parent I'm a
[__] thousand things I love music I
love to eat food you know and that's the
thing if people could just look look at
themselves and be like okay I wanted to
talk about UFC but then there's Rogan
there's fighter and the kid whatever but
I really like horses I really like
taking care of horses I'd much rather
you do
that and and and and do something and
talk about something that you love then
then okay well all these I like UFC my
buddies like UFC we're going to get get
drinks and talk about UFC that's great
you know I'm sure you'll have a good
time what they what they really mean is
I want to have a conversation with my
friends and then just do that but but
it's and there's some of them that are
fine and they're great and there's
different levels so
expectations but to come in with
expectations of being a show that's
going to get ads and you're talking
about the same stuff 7,000 other podcast
are talking about now it's just not
realistic and not that I have the
perfect formula
but I've seen what you've done and
that's really what I've done this past
five years is watch you you ask me qu
you you're very nice you always ask me I
give you some ideas but I really I've
watched
you how you the moves you make and
that's why I get annoyed sometimes the
sometimes I tell Paul you're crazy more
often than now I get pissed
because what you're saying is not what I
was taught and you're going against it
and you're like well [__] them we're
going to do this we're going to do that
and it might not happen 6
months but then it happens like three
and a half years later and I'm like
mother [__] like it just I don't know
and that's what I want but I I don't
think you can do it without the
experience you said about the college
thing earlier I don't I think it's a
very big
difference that first time you're
looking for a job out of college cuz now
the job actually matters listen Lee you
have to lose before you could win why
because that's just the way it is it
makes that win a lot better the moves
you see me do are not because I'm better
than you or I'm pulling whatever on you
or because I've seen these moves already
and I've seen people who fall for tricks
and I've seen people smoke for smoke and
mirrors and what they really want is two
fat [__] talking
right yeah so I could come in here with
a 360° camera and you can look at the
pimple on my neck and the [__] dog
[__] on my sneaker and it's very AV on
guard but we forget what the purpose
is when I went from being what's the
word you said Shady no uh about
expectations oh yeah I went from having
wild
expectations to accepting what I
had I went from wanting to be from a
Dream from let himon coming in to me
saying to myself I'm going to keep
working at
this and eventually I'll turn my life
around I didn't go for the big [__]
picture all I wanted to hear was what
did I really want I didn't I didn't want
to [__] live my life with the cloud
of [__] going to prison all my life
what does that mean that on the 30th of
the month you come to me and you go Joey
we don't have the rent on the first and
all sudden you go in your safe an hour
later and both of your guns are
missing you f me I didn't want that to
ever happen not that I was going to go
shoot somebody but maybe I know where
there's a a pound of cocaine that I
could go rob and 10,000 in cash I was
the type of guy that was that much of a
loose cannon that when things were going
really
well I would have a bad week and [__]
falter like just fall apart and I'd
start thinking about robbing this guy
the contacts I had made the last three
or four months while I was doing great
this one bad thing happened and that end
up right back in Planet [__]
zero now I'd have to leave cuz the
people are looking for their Coke and
they think they know who you know what
I'm saying so I got sick and tired of
living with that I wanted to eliminate
that did I want to be rich not at all I
was content with a single [__] bed a
studio apartment a television with cable
and a shower and a [__] and I could
go to a house what's that place where
you buy food full clothes for Less Food
For Less food no no the other place oh
Ross Ross I go to Ross and I get three
shirts for $18 with a weird Stitch on
the neck I dog I was very content with
that I was very content with that but
then something happened on the way to
[__]
dance because I always wanted to be
Charles Bronson I always wanted to be
Sylvester Stallone and live by myself in
a [__] cave I met a woman and you
know what man it's funny whenever you
pitch a script no matter what script you
pitch they always say to you where's the
love interest and you sit there and you
go this guy don't have no [__] love
interest and all a sudden you realize
that you know what man every great story
has a love
interest and that's what really happened
I ended up meeting my wife I got those
[__] stupid
cats I got a little [__]
responsibility in my life I couldn't put
it all on her shoulders even though I
was addicted to
blow and every month I'd raise my income
by 50 to 100 bucks you know and when
you're doing comedy on commission only
basis people that's a lot that's a lot
to look at you know and I had simple
goals 1,500 2,000 2200 2300 for me it
was a big deal when I stopped losing
money every month just when I broke even
that was so that was exciting for me
just breaking even you know and I think
that people put their expectations high
and then they get cracked you know you
go to school
league you asked me an interesting
question before and I didn't make that
statement to make anybody feel bad you
go to school le you go to college you
marry a high school
sweetheart you have two kids she gains
80 pounds she don't want to suck your
dick no
more you're 35 you've worked at the same
company for eight years for you to get
[__] promoted the guy's got to die
twice and he ain't going to die in the
next 20 years so you're never getting
[__] promoted you know and you look
at all those things and that's when life
becomes hard that's when you see those
people who drink after work that's when
you see substance abuse
problems you're basically
stuck you're
stuck you know you've become a slave to
your [__] stupid [__] you're stuck
man you're [__] stuck man and I've
been stuck we're all [__]
stuck and that's why I think the career
change happens you know I think that my
wife take my wife for example my wife
woke up some morning and she goes I'm
[__] sick and tired of making money
for somebody else of taking care of
other people's money I'm going to take
care of our [__] money I'll do the
paperwork I'll f the taxes I'll do all
that stuff and I'll take care of the
baby and I'll take a chunk out of here
and and that's what we do we make it
[__] work you
know but I think a lot of people one day
they get up man and they go I'm not
doing this no more I'm going to go on my
own and that's where it takes a lot of
balls even if you fail one time I ain't
mad at you because you still took a
[__] shot man I really like if you
don't take that shot lead that's when I
get mad at you if you came to me and and
and December and said you know what dog
I don't want to do the church no more I
love it I still want to be a guest on
here once a month but I don't I don't
want to do it no more I'm going to start
this business if you going to start that
business and after 6 months you don't
like and you you want to come back am I
going to goof on you a little bit I got
to goof on you for 10 minutes because
you made me feel bad on the way out but
at the same time I got a different Keen
of respect for you because now you know
what happened you become a dangerous man
okay you become a dangerous man you
don't leave it's going to take a lot for
you to punch me in the face but if I
kick you in the stomach real hard you'll
punch me in the face the same thing
happens with life Lee sometimes you need
[__] life to kick you in the [__]
stomach and you know Lee I feel bad for
you you ready for this one sometimes it
kicks you once or twice or three
times did did with your dad absolutely
your mom got kicked once or
twice everybody takes a stripe once or
twice it's how you [__] come back
from it brother if you're going to get
depressing and go lay down but if you
come to me and go Jo I got no money in
my refrigerator dog but I got an
idea I want to start a podcast I already
talked to this Advertiser he's going to
give us 300 a month I can work with you
you know what go by the house take the
groceries I give you 200 later for
groceries there's people who bounce back
from that [__] man I got you know you
what the listen let me tell you
something I'm going to look you in the
[__] face and tell you something if
you think prison was a kick in the
stomach to me it wasn't oh my
God it wasn't because I expected it
that's how much of a low life I was from
day one oh my God Joey prison was not a
kick in the stomach to me you know it
was a kick in the stomach to me my
divorce the the the words the lies what
was done afterward I could not believe I
was involved in this situation and I
would never wished on anybody especially
to get Li to and for your ex to move
move your child in with another man and
we could go on here for hours that
destroyed me because I've always said
the hardest thing in life is holding
your little girl and smelling another
man's cologne on it or your little boy
and holding another man's cologne on him
that there's nothing worse than that
[__] uh scent when you have a child
and you get a divorce and all of a
sudden your [__] kid's calling that
[__] Daddy and he's coming to you with
that cologne on and you know and you got
to smell that [__] nothing rips your
insides apart more than that that was
the real kick in the [__] stomach for
me but it was a kick in the stomach and
many levels Le not just I wasn't
heartbroken about it the divorce as much
as what went on after the divorce and
the levels of
pain her lying to the court that that
that I did drugs and she she never did a
drug her moving the kid her not letting
me see the child then I lost faith in
society all over again I was just
getting fith
when my mother died I just started
getting fate you know I wasn't me at the
system for putting me in jail not at all
not at all it was not a kick in the
stomach guys in fact it was an
Illumination in my [__] life what do
you mean illumination it let me know
what I could do and what would I what I
what I could withstand in a thousand
different ways before prison I I can't I
can't live without marijuana I need to
smoke marijuana [__] wait till you go
to prison and ain't no marijuana for you
[__] that got sleep apne and
can't sleep you'll figure it out in
prison and for you non peanut eating
[__] you'll figure it out in
[__] prison peanuts a good net
[__] I don't like sardines wait
till you go to prison wait till you and
your three black buddies are eating
sardines watching a basketball game
eating Saltines and [__] those sardines
dipped in [__] mustard is are good oh
like a [__] when you're in
prison ask me how many sardines I've
eaten lately how many Zelo let me give
some shout outs to get this party
[__] started you know what I'm saying
it's a weird animal Lee it's a weird
kicks in the stomach you're going to get
them and I'm F it's now this is the
beauty of it there's some kicks you
can't avoid there's a thing called life
but there's kicks you can avoid those
are the kicks I want you to avoid I kept
those kicks to a
minimum but people are going to die
things are going to happen to people
that are loved and close to you and they
take a little bit out of your wind by
little you don't even know it that dude
that died that you knew that you didn't
really know they all take a little bit
of the wind out of your sales that's why
eventually you end up dying because the
wind you know what I'm saying like you
lose your spirit in a way you know
but what about when you have a wife and
everything's going great and all you
cheat on your wife or your receptionist
that's 18 and her pussy's tied in death
and next thing you know she calls your
wife and now your wife throws you out
throws you out of your house you just
got kicked in the [__] stomach
and now the 18-year-old is going back
with her high school sweetheart cuz he
di virginized her and taught her how to
suck dick and he promises he won't [__]
the teacher no more so now she goes back
with him so how the [__] are you going
to now you that's kick number one you
got to start from scratch every your job
knows you're a degenerate [__] over an
18y old piece of [__] you're probably
going to lose your job you know so now
what are you going to do now you have to
zero in now you got to really zero in
how do you focus on your life cuz like
we had I had a situation last week where
I didn't realize a situ something I was
doing was was stupid and then when you
look at it you're like oh I was being an
idiot like is it just from doing it too
many times and then realizing it again
or or can you be more focused as a human
being on what you're doing and see
yourself making a mistake you
know I love how people [__] uh drink
Red Bull and take all these pills for
Focus there ain't nothing that alerts
focus more than [__] hunger when when
you're hungry you'll Focus [__] think
about that when you're hungry you'll
[__] focus and you'll zero it all in
and you'll figure out how to do it I got
very hungry after my
divorce I thought about how much things
how many things I [__] up because of
this marriage like how many things I
wanted to do but you had to change your
plans I'm always very happy that I got
into comedy I I was so brained at that
time that I didn't know if I could even
step on stage so I'm very happy that I
got on the stage stage that somewhere a
[__] wind from an Indian God [__]
blew me up to that [__]
stage I'm really happy about that you
know
so like I said if I was 28 I'd stay
single I'd keep my job but at the same
time I'd be starting a business on the
side whether it's online something light
you buy T-shirts from this guy for a
dollar and you sell them to Le for $3
something light same just to teach you
business expectations expectations not
that you're going to make I don't want
you telling your mom you're going to be
a millionaire you're going to sell
little by little and then you get to
meet people and next thing you know
you're printing shirts and next thing
you know you're in uh you're working for
a dude but guess what he's a Coke Fe he
went to rehabs now you took over the
business and you made a profit and when
he got out of jail he didn't he figured
he didn't want to sell t-shirts no more
so he just gives you the business he
sells it to you for a dollar because
you've been such a good [__] dog and
now you have a t-shirt business without
even [__]
knowing that's how fast things could
happen you just look look back after
seven years and you have it and I can't
tell you how many people were trying to
convince me to expand and do more right
when I first started and that's and I
had to fight them they were like oh you
should get in office you should start
pitching to these groups and those
groups and I was like I'm not I don't
want to I don't want to do I'm not ready
for that yet it's people people push you
way too fast I don't know I don't know
if it's Shark Tank or what it is you and
Shark Tank oh [__] yeah Shark Tank
[__] shut the [__] up Shark Tank let
me give some shout outs here as we get
you out of here Shark Tank I'm being
serious Brandy Lynn I love you my girl
Jeffrey Collins always on point Jared
Reynolds my man
Chris Bruins Douglas is dumb I love you
Ernie zots old man
Lou Michael mccan and borderline human
you sexy [__] keep doing what you're
doing I love it you know what I'm
saying I wouldn't uh I wouldn't do
[__]
drugs no I would smoke okay at 28 you're
done you you done your Coke you did your
ecstasy you tried heroin you did an orgy
you had a threesome and now you know
what you want and what you don't
want and that's basically it now you're
set you got your wheels and you're ready
to go
you work for somebody you keep the
lights on you keep your refrigerator you
got your little money you're putting
away your little 401K but at the same
time instead of [__] around and being
part of a fantasy [__] club and
jumping up and down why don't you do
something for two hours a night after
you take a shower and eat dinner and
talk to your girlfriend two hours a
night four nights a week you get online
and you [__] sell t-shirts or figure
out a way how to make though there's a
thousand ways online I didn't have these
options I had to go get 200 qus on their
arm for 400 you know what I'm saying
like you got to get like 100 quays for
200 bucks and sell them for four if you
start with $200 commitments $200
commitments become bigger
commitments people what about it isn't
and I met him small commitments become
big commitments you know how I
know I'm here because of
them in both
directions little commitments become
small commitments the main thing here is
commitment we started off at 100 bucks a
week to do YouTube
videos little commitments become big
commitments if you want them
to but some people have too much
pride and they forget that the little
commitments are how this whole party
starts yeah I'd love to [__] for Exon
to call me and offer me 800,000 a year
as a [__] this but maybe that won't
happen
what if they open a little window for me
and like I said with a little bit of
luck and a little bit of hard work and a
little bit of
patience you know like I tell people you
go to like a place like Aspen Colorado
you know much um any ski resort I'm
sorry to say this you know how much uh
traffic there is in those
places what you like hard traffic like
no how much how many people come and go
okay tons tons which means a guy like
you that's smart that really wants to
put pieces together he'd go to a place
like that and after 2 years he could
excel in something whether it's
something with skis with fitting or
selling skis or working on the mountain
you know there's always a [__] way to
learn you know there's always and
there's different things there's always
you know all right you start at Ral you
start as a [__] clerk parttime all a
sudden you're in the union and a
full-time job opens up and you move into
that and also they're looking for a
night manager a stock night manager at a
different store and you've been there
for 4 years so you got more experience
than anybody also you become the night
stock
manager that really works that really
happens but it's not going to happen if
the little commitment if you didn't
start there as a checker for six bucks
an
hour and if you're not willing to do
that I don't get it I never got
that
what do you think with comedy you think
that we you think they were showing up
with $200 from me to MC the first
week no not even 200 no I was getting I
was getting $50 a show at the broker and
that was like making
$1,000 for an MC you get $15 you get 10
bucks Jesus
Christ anyway talking about small
commitments becoming big commitments
uh 16 years ago I hooked up with my wife
and she had a little cat named finny and
between you and me guys I didn't really
[__] care for him that much I think
my wife babied him too much so I used to
break his balls just to you know make
him [__] be a man I used to chase him
with the vacuum and do crazy [__] like
that you put him through training yeah I
ended up loving this cat I ended up
falling in love with him and everything
cat stood for and then I got Fidel
then I got [__] and
uh we just had a nice little cat family
and then like a year later uh kitten
started popping up and this cat started
killing them so my wife saw the uh they
were living on a roof and she saw the
kitten fall off the roof and bleed from
his nose and the mother walked away from
him because if he if she brought him
with him he'd attract other cats and
kill them so they left Demi there so my
wife brought Demi upstairs and then one
day I was going going somewhere like a
day later and there was a little ball of
gray cat and I'm like and I kept calling
my wife there's a great cat that won't
stop me out and and my wife called me
back and then uh she goes leave him out
there we can't bring him upstairs and
I'm like but he's [__] beautiful and
then she came home and we brought him up
fed him and then that's Harry
today and then we had five [__] cats
and then Austin A year later three you
know it was still [__] mating out
there and now there's four cats out
there and we're trying to give him away
and
anyway to make a long story short uh
this Super Bowl Sunday Anthony
Anderson's going to be having a new show
on Animal Planet that I shot like two
three months ago and I actually told a
story about my super bag cat how I made
a promise and stop snoring Coke and that
was N9 years ago and soup bad's still
alive and they enjoyed the story so they
asked me to put together a
presentation and give it to them and
they're going to make a decision where
the network wants to work with me on a
weekly show you know and it would be uh
like a uh Joey D I'd be like an Anthony
boura cats I would go to Miami and visit
this place and go to Detroit and talk to
these people who make saddles for cats
and go to New York where these guys are
taking pictures of cats with gold and
drugs and guns and [__] like that and
people love their cats and there's a lot
of people love their cats and it's so
weird like I'm not a cat to [__] know
it
all but I know the main thing about a
cat is they want to be
loved that's it you know they just want
to be [__] loved so
uh so that's
uh what I know about cats and over the
years I've talked to different people in
vets and I talked to the cat women in my
neighborhood in fact we're going to have
one of these crazy chicks on the [__]
podcast in a few weeks so I'm going to
put together a presentation for Animal
Planet you know I'm going to go to a
couple places I mean the public will
never see it it's not like I could put
it out there it's it's an interesting
world it's a page it's like a they call
it a scissor wheel or like a
presentation and they just it's like a
little mini version of the show of the
show it's going to be 10 to 12 minutes I
got to go visit a [__]
uh a uh a place where you take your cats
when they're obese okay cool I'm going
to take Harry and Demi they got pretty
big over the last year in a cage and
drive them down there you'll be a part
of
and then I'm going to go talk to you I
read this book called cat Wars and it
talks about the American public uh
killing all feral cats because they're
killing our birds and our rodents but
then you know I read where Disneyland
releases cats at night they have stray
cats and [__] they feed them so they
don't kill the [__] rats and the
rodents they feed them so the scent
throws the rats off because cats are
very Territorial and they do the same
thing down the Flower District District
that here in La the lady does the same
thing she had a lot of rodent from mice
and rats and she got cats so I'm working
a lot off that book to prove some of the
stuff that like I said you know if if my
[__] cat kills your bird my cat's the
underdog you know and I don't mean that
as a joke you got Wings [__] you could
fly my cat can't [__] fly you know
you got that beak you got got the claws
yeah you got a bunch of [__] you know
what I'm saying so my cat catches you he
jumps off a tree what do you want me to
tell you he's not even your [__] bird
and these people give a [__] about some
dirty pigeon and [__] like that you know
and this is the society we live in that
it's an ecosystem Joey yeah it's an
ecosystem and that that they went to New
Zealand and that the [__] cats
destroyed this [__] Island so in
Hawaii they put fences over the [__]
thing I mean you know and I understand I
get it guys but not to be that Gentile
than [__] we rather call all
Americans to kill their feral cats for
love of [__] Christ you know so uh
I'm going to shoot this the week of the
23rd the
24th I'm going to shoot like 4 days just
little footage we got to go to the
Flower District the vet we're going to
interview the vet tech I'm going to have
this dude on the [__]
podcast and uh it's going to be a lot of
fun man I hope it gets picked up so I
can be the new guy and travel around the
country and talk to you [__] Savages
about your cats how's that one for you
mother [__] maybe do a a segment on
cat videos or something every week who
the [__] knows you know but that's what
I'm thinking about doing right now I
don't think I could they keep talking to
me about these TV I don't [__] want
to work on a TV show no I'm having a
good time doing the podcast doing stand
up on the road that doing stand up on
the road I'm
freely I can't I'm too old to be in a
[__] trailer all week and I'm too old
old that was great when I got here and I
was 30 I kind of liked it I don't like
it no more Lee and I'm scared cuz I
might lose my insurance I got to act
every year if not they take them over my
insurance but I just don't know what the
[__] to do I'm not in the mood it's got
to be something I want to do or somebody
I want to work with like Mark Marin show
I had a great time you know I just don't
want to do it no more yeah and but you
like cats that's really cool that's that
you get to focus how how has the process
been cuz you always say that you like to
try new things and this is some this is
something that I've never seen you do at
all well they approached me and they
asked me about what ideas I had and what
they were looking to do and is that
nicer than having to approach them and
Pitch them to have them be like hey how
do you feel about
this yeah it was great it was great I
have them now I at least you're 50% of
the [__] door you they want to see
what you got so I had to really sit
[__] tight for like 2 weeks I don't
know about this world it's not like I
could call somebody and and I just
thought about what was going on and then
I learned a lot from the two guys in
development at the company they
contacted me and we went to lunch and we
just kept talking and talking and
emailing so I learned a lot from what
they wanted to do and then I just took
it back to Simplicity this is just I
have to tell Animal Planet my story and
why I want to do this and what I'm going
to bring to the [__]
table so I started my own little thing I
got to interview my wife I'm going to go
down to Hollywood to show them where I
got the cats from I'm going to show them
uh just like two of the cats I'm going
to show them me driving the cats with my
wife down to the vet me and then me
talking to the lady at the flowers thing
about the book and what she feels and
what she does to control it and then I'm
going to set GoPros around my house so
at night you could see when I get home
stoned to the gills how my cats jump on
me and we play and [__] like that and
that's how the show ends with a little
family type uh thing you know what I'm
saying yeah what kind of thing Joey like
you know The Waltons remember the Walton
at night they say good night Jimmy boy I
believe in that I like that the [__]
dudes the duck family at the end they
always prayed with me I want to show you
the end of the night me sitting there
with my pajamas on drinking a [__]
glass of water and I got super bad Demi
and Harry on my lap and I got gray on my
[__] neck I want to show you people
that so well you always see in TV shows
you always see the dog at the end of the
bed but you don't really ever see cats
always like they don't come on my bed I
have no animals in my bedroom well no
I'm not saying you yeah they don't come
in my bedroom I don't want no [__]
cats in my room they're pain he is no
but you you you interact with them yeah
absolutely why have [__] animals if
you're not going to [__] interact
with them yeah I live and die for those
[__] cats anybody who knows anything
about me I live and die for those cats
you know when I'm home let's say I'm
home for 4 hours every day I got to tell
you something people for 30 minutes I'm
picking one guy up and giving him love
I'm brushing the other girl and play
with the other one you have to do it you
have to mingle with them every day and
have I do something you know I touch
them all before I leave every day every
day before I leave I touch all their
heads that's how superstitious I am
something if demy's close by I'll kiss
him if I could kiss gray I'll kiss her
but whoever sitting there on the way out
to get their head touched do you have a
specific order Lulu's always the last
one because she's by the door really she
hides by the door no no she just sits on
that
chair in fact when I walk in Lulu's eyes
look at me like touch me so I'll touch
it I'll grab her head and sometimes I
sit next to her put my bag on the floor
and just rub her and then I'll talk to
my wife from the living room and she'll
stab me she's got sharp nails and she'll
just [__] stabbed me so I got to pay
attention to her Lulu is a real
sweetheart Lulu is one of my alltime
favor favorite cats a lot of love there
for a female little girl she's a good
lady and she's tougher than [__] she
just doesn't she doesn't uh her and her
sister are tough they just don't
uh floss you know what I'm saying no
they don't [__] floss so I hope it's
going to be an adventure it should be
fun and uh that's what I got for you
that's awesome listen this weekend
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm in
hilarities Pickwick and Frolic downtown
do me a favor come by and say hello
Friday night late my man sto is coming
stopic Maki whatever his [__] name is
the usfc champion he's coming then next
week I'll be at the tempy [__]
improv and that's always I've been going
there since
1997 they don't [__] around there so uh
that's what I got going on man I'm happy
you people listen to them I'm sorry
about the guest cancelled we tried to
give you the best we can we had some
nice [__] conversations tonight I
really wanted to talk talk to you about
that 28 thing because I know there's a
lot of
uh I know there's a lot of people who
listen to this podcast man that are
thinking of starting a business I get a
lot of emails during the week people
asking me questions and that's it man
listen start your business start your
business start your business I'm not
telling you to quit 100% there's a time
to quit and then go to shark tank with
Lee and get mine [__] you don't know
Shark Tank they [__] rob you for
everything you have I'm coming for you
Mark Cuban anyway I want to I want to I
want to talk to you people about
something I've
uh I was never really a big fan of sat
Night Live but somebody told me they
went on ceso and they saw the pilot with
George Carlin and they watched it and
they enjoyed it so that night I went
home I clicked on to ciso and I watched
sat Night Live and I got to be honest
with you I've been watching some of the
Eddie Murphy ones laughing my [__]
ass off all right uh
what's the best thing you bought for
[__] 399 Le you
know ceso has an endless supply of
topshelf com comedy literally months
worth of exclusive Originals face
melting standup and next day late night
and a great catalog of Classics we all
have our own little unique taste you
know what I'm saying like I said I like
sign that live the early ones you might
like the show with that kid with the
suit Paul Tomkins Paul Tomkins show
which is La real estate or something
kind of funny with ceso it's your comedy
get your comedy the way you want it ceso
is the place for comedy they won't tell
you how amazing they are but we will
ceso is amazing they put my special on
and I owe to the end of time it's comedy
for comedy nerds by comedy nerds again
that the standup special from Nick dun
is on there my girl is on there Janine
Garo is on there listen those specials
are hilarious if you want the best new
original comedy you want ciso ceso is
spelled
SEO is the new adree streaming service
bringing you hilarious original series
handpick Classics weeks of standup
specials and more bingeable comedy
anytime anywhere every episode of SNL
ever including new episodes the day
after the air the tonight's show
starring Jimmy Fallon and Late Night
with Seth Meyers the day after they
there so if you miss uh my girl what's
the the blonde that came on here and
killed on Jimmy fron if you miss her El
Eliza you going in the next day and ban
they have Classics like 30 Rock uh lee
show parks and wreck and Saved by the
Bell they got original comedies the
original office with Ricky jeras and the
entire Monty Pyon catalog listen
discover the new Big names and comedy
and watch the icons before they made it
like Louis CK when he had hair Hannah
willberry Chelsea Peretti Amy sh Schumer
Bo baram and a lot more plus you get to
see your Uncle Joey on there all right
they got critical claimed originals and
exclusive content all right so do me a
favor if you're serious about comedy go
to seeso right now and to my listeners
you get seeso free for two months when
you use promo code Joey at the checkout
shows you can't get anywhere else all
right original series like take my wife
and Harmon Quest EST to all 40 Years of
SNL go to seo.com right now and sign up
for two fre months with promo code Joey
at checkout that's seo.com promo code
Joey one of my favorites of all time Lee
Lee loves on this [__] I don't know he's
got to get back on it he's getting a
little moravan over here Lee you gotta
you got to get your [__] together there
[__] you got the you got the girl
moving in with you eating Bon bonss and
[__] at night and making [__] grapes
you were looking all slim Magoo when you
were on Blue Apron they had you on
[__] point you understand me not all
ingredients to create it equal fresh
high quality ingredients make a real
difference so it's important to know
where the hell your food comes from all
right Lee's had a tremendous time making
Blue Apron he's never gotten uh a a bad
dinner you know he's always told me next
day this is [__] pretty good I know
Lee Lee you know Lee eats a lot of
[__] whatever but he tells me how it
is plus him and his girlfriend were
making the meals together it's something
fun to do for less than $10 per person
per meal Blue Apron delivers seasonal
recipes along with proportional
ingredients to make delicious
home-cooked meals choose from a variety
of new recipes each week or or let Blue
Apron culinary team surprise you all
right recipes are not repeated within a
year so you'll never get bored you
customize your recipes each week based
on your preference and there's no weekly
commitment so you only get the
deliveries when you want them and
delivery options you could choose them
to see what fits your needs each meal
comes with a step by step step by step
easy to follow recipe card proportioned
ingredients ready for you all you got to
do is put them in there and they're
prepared in 40 minutes to left 40
minutes or less Blue Apron freshness
guarantee promises that every ingredient
in your delivery arrives ready to cook
or guess what they'll make it right and
they took care of Lee that one time
check out this week's menu all right
let's say you want to do the two-person
plan you got to see a chicken with the
mashed potatoes nice or the pbil style
pork with Citrus rice let's say you want
to do the family plant you got the
crispy cod sandwiches with apple
[__] COA and you got the honey
mustard chicken with the with the wild
vegetables can you beat that at the
house do you know what the hell they
even do you even know how to cook uh
crispy cod sandwiches no you don't
that's why this what I'm going to do I'm
going to give you three meals for free
free and free shipping once you go to
blueapron.com
Joey again free you'll love how good it
feels and you'll love how it tastes to
create incredible homecooked meals with
blue apron so do me a favor don't wait
don't play games go to blueapron.com
Joey start the year off healthy
pre-portion meals you know exactly what
you're putting in your body take a
chance Columbus did go to blueapron.com
Joey I want to thank you guys for
listening you know I love you
[__] with all my heart like I
said Cleveland I'll see you
[__] Thursday night ready to
throw heat stars of De firecrackers
Chinese people whatever the hell you're
doing I'll see you Friday and Saturday
night lisad who loves you more than me
you little [__] Jewish ball of
[__] fire you nobody I love you all
right don't forget about us we'll be
back Monday night with my beautiful Kate
[__] whatever her name is stay black
Uncle Joey loves you have a great
[Music]
weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
it was the 3rd of
September that day I
remember yes
[Music]
I the day that my dad
di I never got a chance to see
him never heard nothing but bad things
about him I'm depending on you tell me
the truth mama just hung her head and
said Son Pap was
Stone where he his was his home and when
he died all left was
alone
Was a Rolling
Stone whereever he laid his his home and
when he only need left
[Music]
alone
hey mama is it true what you say that
Papa never wor your day in his
life and
Mama bad talk around town say to Papa
had three out children and another wife
and that a
right about Papa preaching talking about
saving souls and all the time leing
feeling in that and Stealing In The Name
Of The
Lord
[Music]
M whereever he laid his hat was his home
and when he
[Music]
oh
hey Golden
Stone where he his his home and when
[Music]
he
[Applause]
n
[Music]
[Applause]
he
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Mama I heard Papa call himself a
jack of all tra tell me is that what
said Papa do an early gra folks say papa
would borrow Ste to pay his bills hey
Mama F Papa never Wass much on thinking
spent most of his time chasing women and
drink
Mama I'm depending on you tell me the
truth Mama looked up with a
te a rolling stone well well well well
he was his and when
he all he left us was
[Music]
a he his was his home and when
he all he left us was
[Music]
alone he
his
and he
[Music]
left
[Applause]
[Music]
oh